as we were revealed on wednesday nevada
voters are unhappy and undecided more
than half think the country is going in
the wrong direction president biden's
approval rating is around 33 percent and
these results show why a sliding stock
market rising inflation unaffordable
housing it's little surprise what nevada
voters are most concerned about it's the
economy our poll shows 34 percent
believe that is the important issue in
the state in second nevada's water
supply followed by education and housing
on the campaign trail it's hard for
democrats to lean into the nation's
economy but emerson college pollster
spencer kimball says water rights seem
useful right now the democrats are doing
very well on this issue and it's heard
it's helping both in the senate and the
governor race but again it's the economy
which overshadows everything when asked
what should be blamed for rising
inflation more than 42 percent say the
byte administration far behind supply
chain disruptions and the war in ukraine
on high gas prices the story is the same
46 percent of nevada voters blame
president biden in his policies after
that oil companies and sanctions against
russia reviewed journal politics editor
steve sebelius says it could spell
trouble for democrats in november the
trends are
looking towards a red wave
in november and
and i don't think candidates can rely on
that and just sit back on their laurels
tonight at six we'll take a closer look
at nevada's congressional and senate
races which could help flip the party in
power in washington john langler live
local now